I heard of the biggest hockey fan in
town here oh yeah
we did something in your garage love to
show you
oh wow today's gonna be awesome because
I'm surprising a young hockey fan With a
Little Help from hgtv's Dave and Jenny
Mars and my Wells Fargo active cash Visa
card
I'm here in Fort Morgan Colorado at the
tail end of a project I've been working
on with Dave and Jenny they've already
renovated the garage of a high school
senior here before I head to the house
I'm gonna pick up one last thing I want
to add to the room hey how can I help
you I ordered the sign I'm here to pick
it up the names under Nathan McKinnon oh
just a second I heard the sign's awesome
Tyler's gonna love it so I'm excited to
check it out here look at that that's
beautiful love the burgundy the white
the mountains that hockey player it
looks great thank you this is awesome no
problem have a wonderful day thank you
it's going to be great to surprise Tyler
with this
hey Nate how's it going yeah I'm just
calling to let you know how cool this
room is uh you guys absolutely crushed
the design you know everything you would
need in uh you know hockey fans room so
really cool great how's the sign look
the sign is a cool thing growing up I'd
love to have my own name in my hockey
room or garage or whatever so it looks
great and I'm glad I could add something
well we are so excited for Tyler to see
it and to meet you he'll be a little
more excited to see the garage than me
but I'm glad I could be here
hey what's up man hey oh my gosh Hi how
are you Tyler nice to meet you nice to
meet you oh my gosh I heard of the
biggest hockey fan in town here like
recapping all the games you're talking
about yeah I do yeah that's great I love
watching love watching you I love
watching like kale and stuff yeah yeah
it's pretty good oh yeah just all right
she's all right yeah I'm trying to stick
for you yo that's cool bro thanks did
something in your garage for you see if
you like it better than the old garage
oh wow
wow
wow dude I think it's awesome I think so
too I wish I had this when I was younger
as well oh yeah compared to what it was
for my things scattered everywhere yeah
kind of like a big storage unit
essentially essentially yeah I just
can't believe how much it's changed so
your parents have to put their stuff in
your hockey garage now yeah yeah nice
spot now we had so much love and support
through our title run in Denver and all
over Colorado to give back to a smaller
town in Colorado that you know doesn't
always get to come to the games because
of the distance give back to Tyler do
this room for him it feels great place
to Mayor hockey sure let's do it let's
go
got the angle
oh nice
[Music]
I'll go to three two on you
OT
oh
that was lucky
hey let's go
yeah man you beat me three too I got a
couple lucky ones but uh he all played
me pretty badly you're the honors
getting to play air hockey with Nate was
like almost a dream to me it didn't
really feel real until I beat him good
luck this year appreciate that yeah I'll
be watching all the games that I can you
like your room love it already but Dave
and Jenny did a pretty amazing job yeah
they did that was amazing I love how
everything came together and I love that
I earned unlimited two percent cash
rewards on purchases with my Wells Fargo
active cash credit card
see you later